[Music]
[A solider wearing an apron puts on a facemask.]
[Narrator:] You may not believe it, but this is really Private McGillicuddy!
[Washes hands and prepares an alcohol solution.]
[Narrator:] And his unusual activity is quite a surprise.
Facemask, rubber gloves, disinfectant. Looks like he's preparing for an important operation.
And he is! He is going to wash his mess gear.
Although he's knocking himself out with all
this surgical etiquette, there's good reason for it.
Mac is not taking any more chances.
So draw up a foxhole and we'll tell you why.
Once upon a time, McGillicuddy ignored the
commandment:
[Sign tacked to tree reads Fifth Commandment: Mess Gear]
[Narrator reading sign:] Thou shalt carefully and faithfully wash thy mess gear both before and after meals.
For verily if thou become negligent in this
habit, thy guts shall be like knots in a wet rope.
[Narrator:] So, while the other men went through their usual routine
of cleaning their mess gear in scalding, hot soapy water,
McGillicuddy would stash his lazy butt under a coconut tree and wash his gear in his own way.
[McGillicuddy licks his mess gear, puts dirt or sand inside it, shakes it around,
wipes the gear with his shirt, and his mess gear shines.]
[Narrator:] Sure, it looks clean - but it isn't!
You can't clean your mess gear by lickin'
it!
[McGillicuddy:] You can't?
[Narrator:] Naw, that just makes it look pretty! Here, look at it through this magnifying glass.
[Magnifying glass appears above mess gear and spots of food are seen for the first time.]
[Narrator:] You see those little spots? They're bits of decayed food.
No telling how long they've been there!
Now watch closely.
[Zoom-in on decayed food. A lizard-like germ crawls out of food.]
[Narrator:] Cute ain't he? That is a germ!
You ain't seen nothing yet. Take another gander.
[McGillicuddy looks back at germ.]
[Narrator:] Now watch him multiply.
[Germs continue to split into other identical
germs.]
[Narrator:] 2! 4! 8! 16! 32! 64! 128! 256...
[Narrator becomes inaudible as he continues to count even faster and then skips to final number.]
[Narrator:] 8,970,562!
If you haven't been washing your mess gear properly, you've been eating those dirty microscopic scavengers!
[McGillicuddy looks sick and quickly runs to wash his mess gear in multiple tubs of scalding hot soapy water.]
[He finishes with a sigh of relief.]
[Narrator:] Well, that's more like it!
And that isn't all. You gotta wash it again
before you eat.
Otherwise stray insects, like this fly for
instance, will foul it up again!
Maybe he's just been to the privy, maybe a garbage dump,
and undoubtedly is packed with dysentery germs.
[A fly with dirty dripping feet lands on mess
gear and skates around, leaving behind a trail of dirt.]
[Narrator:] If you're not careful, McGillicuddy, you will be too!
[McGillicuddy Is napping and is oblivious to the fly.]
[Narrator:] What's more...hey, ya knucklehead, wake up! I'm talkin' to ya!
There's a fly on your mess gear!
[McGillicuddy wakes up, swats the fly away, and looks proud of himself.]
[Narrator:] Now don't forget to wash that thing before ya eat.
[Bugel sounds as Mac runs off with his mess gear.]
[McGillicuddy runs past soldiers washing mess gear, knocks over the bugel player, and is first in line for food.]
[Narrator:] That's right, Mac. First in line, last in brains.
Let him pile all that good wholesome food
on top of those germs.
[McGillicuddy stumbles out of mess tent, begins contorting himself and placing his hand over his stomach. He passes gas.]
[X-ray view of guts; narrator's voice booms
as guts are tied into knots.]
[Narrator:] Remember, Mac: "Thy guts shall be like knots in a wet rope!"
[McGillicuddy imagines himself in bed.]
[He imagines a large monster-like doctor towering over him,
about to cut into his stomach with a large knife.]
[Then sees a sinister-looking doctor plunging his face with a toilet plunger.]
[Next, two surgeons saw him in half
with a saw.]
[McGillicuddy imagines looking upwards and seeing a ring of grinning, snickering doctors.]
[Then he sees himself being forced to drink a giant bottle of castor oil...]
[imagines himself being held down with his
bottom facing a doctor...]
[who holds a hose connected to a tank that
says Capacity 50 Gal.]
[The tank empties into the hose and the soldier screams in pain.]
[McGillicuddy is then seen scrubbing his mess gear vigorously.]
[Narrator:] And so, kiddies, that is the story of Private McGillicuddy and the bad little germs,
and how he learned to wash his mess gear and live happily ever after.
[Music]